[Music]
welcome back tradition welcome back to
the jinjo chess with our first ever is
this I actually didn't even check this I
think it's our first ever guests in our
new house is it welcome mat Jose to the
podcast
thanks it's tradition truly an honor and
a privilege oh please
well it's not a full honor cuz you don't
get headphones you have to listen to
this with your normal years because we
haven't really settled up for three
people yet but we did our best and I'm
behind a big that's fine you can hear
him that's all that matters
they can well we'll see you later yes
welcome back to the gingely in podcast
this episode was brought to you by post
mates yay
aka sponsored by snacks and food and
delicious things brought directly to you
yay for very very little hassle post
mates is the app that has delivery
service for places that don't offer
delivery they're picking up the pieces
where other businesses fall short and
they bring you delicious things at all
hours so check them out my downloading
the post mates app you use code Jenna
Julian for $100 off free delivery
credits your first seven days on the app
cannot promote that app enough I love it
well okay so I think we we have a couple
things we want to talk about but I want
to give a nice grand intro to someone
who deserves it and that Jose is a
friend of mine he's been internet did
you turn around that's good we've been
internet friends for a few years now
yeah almost like two and a half yep tuna
yes we have a close who knows maybe your
anniversary's coming up hope you
remembered
I found mass I found that's work you had
one of your time-lapse reels go semi
viral when kind of ages ago 2013 that
one I don't know maybe it was maybe well
I found you like basically for me I
think was like three years ago yeah you
might have gone like you know how some
things like blow up and then they
started Reba ghin yeah I think he might
have been one of the the second times
but you had a reel of yours kind of go
big matt is a professional time lapse
photographer and hyperlapse photographer
/ videographer you do all kinds of cool
work but I found your real and I
immediately was like okay who the [ __ ]
is this guy
subscribe yeah because it was a I saw a
little bit of you too well I think what
separated that reel was like it wasn't
just a compilation of cool shots with
music and then it's over it was like it
was that but then I got to see who the
guy was behind the camera which was cool
so I immediately subscribed and I was
like a lurker for a while then I
commented and we connected and we've
been kind of internet friends for a
while now and you're visiting here in LA
specifically to be on the podcast no
other reason at all this is a very
expensive episode for me now you here
for Adobe MAX amongst other things and
people you're meeting and just but you
like to do this lot on your videos where
you point the camera at someone say
describe yourself so I'm gonna do that
to you now if you could just give us a
short little brief thing for people know
a little little bite-sized Matt Joe's
description it's actually quite
interesting you the first I've been
doing that exactly like four years tell
people who are you and what do you do
and use the first person no one's ever
done it back what a moment it's a lot of
pressure it's a lot of pressure
I mean word again we talk a lot and you
did it to me the other day so I'm
enjoying my name is Matthew Van de puta
it's a pressing I know you're gonna ask
I'm as Jillian said it time-lapse
hyperlapse photographer videographer and
youtuber from Belgium Antwerp represents
living in Sydney Australia and I I love
time-lapse travel and tutorials is
pretty much what I'm all about
I went to this is it same I just not
disappointed but I got a film school my
probably not it's really expensive in a
way I guess here it is yeah and there's
so much different like old movies yeah
that was cool that's probably
highlighter yeah yeah that was did you
have to watch casablanca I should
I never watched that ones I don't hate
it I just got drunk women and watched it
podcast oh no that was actually that was
one of the cooler things of being in
films I went to film school too but it
wasn't like film school film school I
was going for broadcast journalism so I
didn't get to do all the creative fun
stuff like make many movies and use the
sets and all that and we just kind of
where the talking heads but we did have
like a lot of our assignments were watch
old movies yeah well I was a I went as
an editor so I'm a trained video I
didn't over film editor documentary I
didn't really so we were like the nerds
because everyone else it was audio
imagery or editing and the two other
courses were always on set and on
location doing stuff and all we got to
do on set was like where's the map
where's the memory card then we had to
like go back and edit and yeah we were
not the cool people yeah
did you have like in film school did you
before he picked like an emphasis and
we're you did you have to play all the
roles it all was like the first I think
the first six months of the course is
like a general like but you get a little
bit and then I kind of taste it all and
then they ask you to choose and to me
editing I think you both would know it's
just so much fun because you can you can
like shift storylines and and push
people to I don't know it's like
puzzling puzzled monster the puzzle
master Thank You Man hi I'm an editor
but you can just call me the puzzle
master Hey yeah we shot man I shot the
Pad Thai video together and it was well
received because it was like a cool
fusion of you're shooting in my own age
at school and it was good Pad Thai as
well yeah a little bit more about that
okay I mean a spicy he almost killed me
I did another one was kill him I just
gave him the heat I gave him the heat I
felt that hey hold on you were a little
sick before and I where'd your sinuses
write up hope yeah you're welcome
for the food and anyway healer a puzzle
master and you know we want to talk
about scary things because we promised
that the rest of the hawk tober podcast
would be Halloween or spooky themed
although we're not in costume this week
sorry my toothbrush costume was a little
big for a three-person setup I know
tried it on it's very comfortable yeah
is comfortable it's not very portable
either it almost broke so what I thought
would be fun would be to kind of we each
have like well actually this was kind of
generous and Matt's idea but it would be
like we each pick something that we're
scared of and we talk about it sort of
like it already like a spooky therapy
session I'm scared
wait a minute therapy scares me that's
my scared no I'm just kidding it was
terrified I've done therapy therapy is
wonderful
but Jenna has picked out some things I
have a couple things and Matt has some
stories
mmm never gonna go through and talk
about what scares us hopefully to make
it so we're not scared by them or is
that not the goal absolutely not the
never night we're never talking about
scary things
sorry returning no if you think doing a
podcast with some kind of catharsis is
gonna get me to not be scared of it you
crazy okay you sound really scared I'm
scared tell me why you're so scared
things I'm scared of everything I'm
scared of heights hotel rooms that are
up high needles like anything I've
missed you in person
blockade the hotel balcony door before
we went cuz I'm scared I'm gonna fall
out of it bunk in the bedroom you're
gonna go through rooms and fall out it's
an irrational fear I'm aware that it's
rational but it doesn't take it away
from me yeah I'm scared of no I'm just
trying to validate your claim here I've
seen you actually block ADA the balcony
so that's a thing I'm scared
okay so Heights check needles needles
why you scared needles I don't like when
it goes into your arm or like in your
hand like an IV or like when you have to
get blood right I don't like it what
would you do if you had to like get
needles in your arm all the time well
okay so when I was in like third or
fourth grade we were watching a cartoon
about drugs you know like don't do drugs
and they showed a scene of someone doing
heroin and like you know getting all
bubbly and whatever and I passed out as
a fourth grader and I had to go to the
principal and they were like are your
parents feeding you and I was like yeah
I just didn't like that video
Oh like I have a problem passing out
sometimes if something scares me I'll
pass out which is why I have to look
away during like very gory TV scenes or
like any Hospital show I just can't
watch really scary movies yeah like some
of the more gory stuff like I really
just can't it like it makes the backs of
my legs go numb and then my arm just
kind of go numb and then I pass out well
yeah that's the truth I don't like it
okay anyways but that's not what I
wanted to talk about what I mean I'm
scared of plenty of things honestly and
you're scared of everything yeah it's
like the older you get and then like
Matt was just saying that he's scared of
someone like when you're waiting for a
subway or a train that something's gonna
push you in front of it but like I won't
there goes my story thank you train like
all day every day and like never once
thought of getting pushed until Matt
said that now I'm scared of that sorry
my bad well that impulse is the scary
part of that yeah we'll get to that wait
so go ahead talk about what I'm
releasing yeah I want to hear the the
real boy right I'm I'm I've always been
scared of like demons like ghosts I feel
like I'm not terribly scared of because
I feel like they're sort of people
trapped and like an in-between place or
like it you're not scary at all
I mean I'm scared of them but I don't
think that they're gonna hurt me you
don't mean mm-hmm
a demon though terrified of demons
absolutely terrified of demons so
they're nasty and like they're just like
they can do crazy [ __ ] and they make
weird noises so define appear evil what
just so we know like it would define the
demon that you're talking about like is
it does it take the form of getting
their questions I have questions I'm
scared of being possessed I am deathly
afraid of being possessed ever since I
saw the exorcism when I was like a
little girl cuz I saw it like way too
young and then it couldn't sleep for
like a couple days which is very
traumatic when you're like eight you
know yeah because you need sleep because
you've been running all day being a
child but I'm scared being possessed
so I occasionally have looked up like
people getting possessed cuz if you like
it happened in like the 60s 70s and
before that and like places that you're
like oh that's that's some other place
whatever but there's one in here that
happened in 2008
2008 people are still out you again
possessed by the devil
wait so that's the most recent case I
don't know but I wanted to read you some
cases 10 years ago it's old news come on
you're fine mm-hmm where was it
California can I like can I get there
you're just gonna like sorry that I'm
interested in your story okay well then
let me tell you some stories cuz I'm
gonna read you right now
all right 11 real-life cases 1100 down
wait so these are like faked all right
they're all movies I'm sorry I'm just
you're easy to mess with right now okay
you're you're like vulnerable and scared
it's kind of fun get you a man that
messes with you when you vulnerable
all right you did you ever see the
extras The Exorcism of Emily Rose yes
that movie yes I watched that in college
it's really scary so that movie was
based on a person named Anneliese Michel
and I have audio it's on YouTube of her
like speaking in voices and being
possessed she was 16 years old
struggling with epilepsy and mental
illness and was exposed to a brutal
exorcism upon suicidal tendencies in
1973 her behaviors like repelling
religious artifacts hearing mystical
voices and drinking her own urine will
make you wonder if people are too
oblivious to make take such accounts
seriously Julian you're the person
that's not taking it seriously you think
there's that girl who's just drinking
their own pee she's 16 and I'm like no
dude that's not normal
she got a demon inside of her okay all
right and what is he doing what is he
doing hey Kermit why are you looking
he's licking the floor in the closet
classic that's disgusting that's that's
what I'm scared of that thing in the
closet okay the floor that he looks up
for you and then his eyes just light up
and he's drooling cuz he's feral he's
foaming at the mouth
all right would you like to hear some
stories of people being possessed cuz
it's a real thing that happens and I
feel like it's gonna happen to me and
I'm scared and I don't want it to happen
I want to hear some stories is that I
have so many questions for this Clara
German SLA
a student at
Michael's mission in South Africa Celie
who confessed to making a pact with
Satan which sometimes I feel like is the
key like these people though but some of
them aren't they didn't ask for it at
all that like one of them was like he
was just trying to make contact with his
dead relative using an Ouija board
I is that a dog barking yeah or it's
it's a demon scared okay some people I
feel like we're making pacts with Satan
and then it happens and other people are
just doing stuff trying to talk to
people I wonder what makes a person want
to do that probably a lot of things okay
she was reckoned as possessed in 1906
for showing unnatural impulses she was
reported to levitate up to five feet and
make peculiar inhuman cacophonous her
exorcism was witnessed by over a fee her
exorcism was witnessed over 170 people
where she knocked out Bibles behaved
wildly and tried to strangle a priest
with his own stole the two days hysteria
ended with her levitating before
descending still okay can I just
levitate it up and then she just fell
still to the ground I just got to jump
in here oh I need to jump in here right
what five feet yeah what is the NBA
doing she can levitate five feet she
would absolutely own everybody if she
could control that and not only would
she just legitimately just do whatever
she wanted against any NBA player she
wouldn't play she's possessed by the
devil
well then the devil could play what if
the devil likes to bowl honestly valid
the devil might like a lot of sports but
maybe just push the devil to wanna play
basketball because if they could
levitate 5 to 5 feet to maybe even
higher and make crazy noises you're just
winning every what makes you think that
that person's gonna be a team player
they don't need a team 1 d 5
well destroy put him in the Olympics the
high jump
they are already jump they're already
above it they're standing in the air
okay we're in the rule book does it say
the devil can't compete wait it might
say that's you can't yeah well you said
170 people witnessed
millions of people could witness it if
she was on TV don't get on Fool's
fifteen-year on her feet
then so are you saying that you don't
think that being possessed by a demon
surreal thing no I'm just asking
questions Matt do you think it's a real
thing I don't know I I don't think so
look if that's the thing then truly like
we would have seen much much more that's
my thought too but I'm also afraid to
say no because then someone's gonna get
possessed right in front of me and I'm
loose on it this is the same like of
course not exactly cut yeah I think a
thousand percent it's a thing because
it's cross-cultural and it's been
happening for centuries okay I want to
hear that longer I want to hear more
stories from from okay number two Julia
hmm a case documented in 2008 by dr.
Richard E Gallagher a psychiatrist in
New York chronicles the story of his
patient who he deemed to be possessed
after seeing objects floating in the air
her clairvoyance about surrounding
people hateful rants and periodic
levitation during her exorcisms plural
the room apparently became
excruciatingly Li hot while she
vehemently repulsed holy water upon
waking from these trances she would have
no memory of what went down how do you
explain that 2008 I find that to be
annoying I graduated because she just
like wakes up she's like I don't know
what happened
can't blame her responsibility really
anything yes sorry well that's
interesting because one of these
involves a case where they're the first
and only person to plead not guilty
because of demonic no [ __ ] number three
George Lucas an English tailor George in
the late 1700s indulged in erratic
behavior we ran he's saying and spoken
spooky voices and strange languages
after claiming to be possessed doctors
surrendered and he went on his own way
only to get more hostile and animalistic
in nature for years to come the
self-claimed Devil's exorcism called for
a gathering of seven priests and the
madness ended with him praising the Lord
and accrediting the priests not that
good okay I will find you okay this one
Roland
the inspiration for many fictitious
adaptations like The Exorcist and
possessed the story of this man is
hauntingly tragic the boy of 14 years
old ok 14 you're telling me that he
wants this no he wants to eat chicken
nuggets and play basketball with his
friends he's 14 years old not with that
possessed chick he'll get owned whose
know he would play against her yeah
because he's also possess that's a 1v1
I'd watch ok the boy of 14 is actual
actual name was Roland Edwin hunkler had
a tryst with demonic possession in an
attempt to contact his dead aunt using
an Ouija board sounds familiar
so he like you know got mixed up with
some bad spirits with mysterious
scratches on the skin flying religious
artifacts
guttural splutters body contortion and
levitation guttural splutters throwing
up or something I think Gutter looks
like like it really like Wikipedia
hearse isms as a 14-year old Julian
there's no predictive text on this on
Google where he even entered the booth
the final exorcism involved a feral
anguish and sulfuric older looming in
the air [ __ ] this boy is 14 years old
you tell me he wanted that and he's just
trolling people do you reckon a lot of
these are just like illnesses big
physical mental yeah I feel like that's
kind of the easy all right so I googled
guttural sputtering and it took me to a
Google+ page and it just says looks like
you've reached the end all right cool
spluttering with it are you ready for
Arnie Cheyenne Johnson back you marked
in history for being the first person to
plead innocent on account of demonic
possession
Arnie's case is well known as the demon
murder trial his trial involved strange
claims by people in his vicinity such as
the presence of an apparition with
demonic eyes and beastly features he was
in for stabbing his landlord while
growling infernally and got convicted
serving a sentence of five years for a
typical 10 to 20 years crime
so they literally cut his sentence in
half because he claimed they must have
had really strong evidence that this man
really out here being possessed by what
year was that marble we're podcasting
doesn't say we can why don't you google
the demon murder trial it's called the
demon murders what was it don't know
that was my question
murder trial trial of orange Cheyenne
Johnson is that it yeah 1981 I did 81
there's a couple years before I was born
eighties tudm eighties be like well
right Anna Eckland this grotesque story
of this fourteen-year-old girl like what
why why her I don't know that sounds
awful born in 1882 is infamous as the
erling possession cursed by the
witchcraft practiced by her father and
aunt okay witchcraft alright Anna became
intolerant towards religious artifacts
was sexually vile and couldn't set foot
in a church a successful attempt at an
exorcism was made but the demonic
possession was back as her folks begged
Satan for it admitted in a convent she
hissed threw away a blessed some blessed
food levitated spoke foreign languages
and could cling into walls
she deformed in appearance and after 23
days and three exhaustive exorcisms she
was cured of evil possessions but her
parents were like asking for it why I
don't know that seems just all-around
weird the whole levitation things so
like I asked you at it and she did but
what like that's just like casually
written it's like it doesn't matter
where it is in the world or when it is
they all have these similarities of like
speaking in tongues making all the
noises you know an aversion to religious
artifacts and levitating so I I will say
like from the exorcism related movies
that I've watched like The Exorcism of
Emily Rose and like whatever else in the
media that I've seen it's [ __ ]
terrifying
like I'm on film it's scared it's like a
perfect horror medium for for you know
no pun intended for a
entertainment but like I want to know
what it would be like in person when
that happened and how close to that it
would actually be like do they actually
like do they actually like Bend in ways
that humans shouldn't Bend these are
saying I know but like these are written
accounts like I'm not doubting them I'm
just saying like I'm very curious as
because I don't I don't fully like
disbelieve this I just think that it's
interesting to think about like in real
life you know because like for instance
like to kind of translate or you know
back to ghost stories or whatever like
people I trust you roam people who swear
on everything that they've seen or heard
a ghost like it's obviously very
different from how its portrayed and say
movie or something but it's still very
real and scary so I would love to know
like the real I want to see some real
footage of some demons and some
possessions that's what I'm trying to
say okay well I'll try and find you some
but I do have an audio I wanna hear
audio okay um the last one I'll say is
Son of Sam since you're scared of serial
killers um
Son of Sam the serial killer who made
New York terror-stricken in 1976 went by
Son of Sam and the 44 caliber killer
reports confirm that six people died and
seven got wounded in the summer of Sam
after he was taken into custody he
confessed all his crimes and it started
that a demon residing in his neighbor's
dog ordered the killings he was
incarcerated with six life sentences he
admitted to being part of his satanic
cult and perpetuating the murders as a
ritual offering [ __ ]
okay satanic cult that's one thing that
scares me like not just one person a
group of people culture just scary and
Jack Larson doesn't have to be satanic
can be something else mm-hmm
that's true are you ready are you ready
for some audio of the possession of the
real Emily Rose dude so I'm gonna I'm
gonna read these subtitles for you so
you know what's going on you're
translating what they're saying yeah all
right this is normal Anneliese Michel
which is her name
that's her normal speaking voice Ramos -
Shh and then this is hold them why is
that hallo yeah marvel stop here she was
apparently possessed by six demons and
these are the different demons one of
which apparently is Hitler Wow so here's
a bad one
I didn't know he was considered a demon
but he might now be and you heard her
speaking voice this is the voice coming
out of her this is Kane
who's that like super calm and collected
person probably a priest doing the
exorcism horrifying absolutely
horrifying I got nothing got a few
goosebumps that's what I wanted to see
in here at Julian here you go DeNiro
these are pictures of her by the way I
don't I don't know what they're saying
and this is a young girl yeah like why
you shouldn't be able to make that noise
turn her face oh my god
okay the music Judis like for all the
you know it could be some type of mental
illness going on or that kind of thing
like what what is this then dog Lucifer
okay what is that
[ __ ] hell God what the hell no pun
intended so anyways that's what I'm
scared of what about y'all guys alright
I gotta go no that's [ __ ] terrifying
yeah I'm like I'm not discounting your
fear like that [ __ ] is horrifying it is
rational means like maybe it's a vocal
thing like it but but like on the other
side like that mmm that's pretty wack
putting yourself in a situation where
that person actually saw that in person
like the priests or the parents or
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ] dude everything you
thought you knew about anything just
even like the you know the smaller
stories about people having demonic
interactions they're different than a
ghost or like different than some sort
of other being you know what I mean cuz
they're they're pure evil like there's
evil going on you know any time an evil
and the person just becomes the vessel
they're not a person anymore it's like
their personality and brain v everything
yeah completely that's [ __ ] to it but
like what always scared me about
possessions was that like yeah obviously
some of these people are involved in
some they're trying to contact Satan or
like things like that yeah but then
there's these young teenagers like using
Ouija boards or just like becoming a
vessel for a demon like just because
they've opened a portal or something
right yeah yeah have you ever actually
played a wheel yes when we used to play
um psychic circle with my friends so
were you literally like light candles
and did the would you thing move yeah
what was the Ouija Berkeley I mean I
could never tell like I was younger so
to always play with like my friends and
I couldn't really tell if they're being
shits or not but I've had bad
experiences oh it was like it's a
phenomenon that happens with Ouija
boards where it spells zo zo zo and goes
back and forth back and forth so people
were like oh it's the famous Ouija demon
Zozo but really like I forget who
theorized it but that it's like a spirit
or a demon playing a trick on you it's
not their name
but but the repetition of it going back
and forth and back and forth is what is
actually opening like the portal for
them to be able to come all of us yes
yeah men see it you know when you hear
something and it triggers a memory yeah
like 20 years ago I read this book about
like kids playing with Ouija boards and
like oh we're gonna summon this demon
and then [ __ ] goes down yeah like it
stuck with me because I'm so young yeah
when I read it and it was like oh I
didn't sign up for this but it was too
captivated yes to stop reading that's me
in a nutshell so captivated to stop
listen into that video when I couldn't
know I mean the caps when you start
watching you're like I gotta keep I
gotta keep learning this no you said I
was afraid of cela killers I'm not
afraid of serial killers anymore than
anyone else is afraid of serial killers
but there was this one night that like
we're like I've been reminded of
sometimes when I'm like home alone cuz I
was home alone one night you were gone I
forget for what and I was just like
watching TV and it was like dead quiet
and then all of a sudden just I got the
door sorry sorry then that's what
happened except they weren't freaking
out it was something I heard dogs in
freaked out hey so I heard that you guys
are messing up my bit here you're
messing up my bit so I heard that and
that's funny and so I'm like alone right
so I'm like what like who and it's late
so I go to the door it is my post name
I forgot I ordered postmates oh you guys
can order this right are you serious by
going to the post made up for your first
week is a wonderful app you can get
delivery from all sorts of different
restaurants that might be actually too
busy to go to or if you're isolated
introvert like me and you don't like
going places you can just order post
mates and being your pajamas all day
marble the bits over dude it's over you
can stop
anyway post mates is wonderful guys if
you need some groceries or you need
something from a store or if you just
want one Gator you can get a post mate
to do it for you because they're
standing by ready to help you at your
every need in the delivery world post
mates is something that we use all the
time whether we go shopping and for
get one thing or it's Sunday and it's
time to eat cheetah food and we want
pizzas and paddle somewhere else you can
always cook you can always wants to do
that okay
anything you want Pizza Indian food a
salad breadsticks
you don't want to get on the phone and
hello can you hear me and it's loud on
the other end and you're like I want to
be on my phone I'm on my phone anyway
let me just order some food real quick
just download the postmates app enter
your location and you can see what's in
your area on post minutes it'll blow
your mind it's great if you have not
tried it check it out download post
mates and use code Jenna Julian okay
because you get a hundred dollars of
free delivery credit for your first
seven days get the food you look fast
that post mates thank you for sponsoring
this episode I'm mad at you for that by
the way I thought that was very exciting
it would have been better if they didn't
school Alex if they didn't freak out but
I guess that was part of it but again
the trigger for me that reminded me I
was in Melbourne last year big city in
Australia also post mates like post mate
yeah yeah yeah anyways it probably vibes
with Australians you don't have post
mates out home that's what I would use I
would use it all the time because
there's always something I can be yeah
you know I don't want and I've heard the
horror stories not literal Horrors but
like really miserable experience from
other delivery services yeah oh it sucks
really bad anyways the knock on the door
thing I was in Melbourne for like like
maybe it was VidCon or something or like
a road trip with my brother and he was
out on a date I think and I was just in
our you know an apartment that we were
renting on the couch few beers in just
like scrolling Twitter whatever and all
of a sudden the door opens opens so he
meant like I'm on the couch and at my
feet to the left is the door and it
swings open like so the hinges are at my
feet and then the door opens so I can't
see who is coming in so my god Timo and
the door it stops opening I was like
Timothy and the door closes and that's
when I'm like what I'm getting
goosebumps not thinking back about cuz
this is like some real [ __ ] I'm not
joking and I was like on my phone like
Timo but are you like where are you in
the car weird at this restaurant he
replied
after like 15 minutes but I was freaking
the [ __ ] and you were I was like I
literally all I pretty much froze I was
like I don't know what to do in this
situation
yeah because something like ah you know
you think of like someone's gonna walk
in randomly in your apartment
but someone actually did and I did not
imagine this cuz I I got up and I was
like I think you put the door like
against the thing so I closed the door
like turn the lock which I should have
done before that obviously doors just
open but it was in like an apartment
look like you needed a key to get into
the main thing yeah and I was like my
heart rate was through the roof and I
was again like a few beers and I was
like wait what like am i imagining this
what's going on and I remember just
standing there holding that doorknob not
knowing what to do
cuz you like the the feeling of freezing
I can I can really do
cuz that's that's the thing when you you
can't really believe what's going on
it's like you're just trying to
comprehend this person walking or was it
yes someone or something someone opened
the door and then shut it well once you
said and then once I was like Hello like
it wasn't the style of door opening were
you walk into your own apartment cuz
I've done that wrong yeah it wasn't that
it was something else it was you can
tell by the casing yeah it was like too
slow it was too slow and I'm like I'm on
my phone and in the behind my periphery
yeah see the door opening oh my god timo
and then that's kind of when it stopped
I was like how old are you
this is the year and a half ago that is
I'm 21 29 I was 28 no you were like it's
close to like a home invasion yeah sure
yeah that was if that was that like it
may be a bad area or yeah the wrong
person with something yeah I would have
been a really bad yeah that's what the
reality of it was so bad to me that that
happened two times where someone just
walks into my house one was at our old
house do you remember when that guy was
looking for like that group home and he
just walked through the door so small so
I'm your mom was visiting - yeah I was I
was in the front hall and I seen this
guy drive around he's
very old guy just driving around his car
he gets out of his car comes up to our
door which you could easily do to our
last house I opened the door and he has
sunglasses on and he looks very like out
of it just disoriented and he's like I'm
looking for the the home like the didn't
say like that I wasn't like I'm looking
for the hole it was like a retirement or
some some sort of assistant loan or
something
he was like is this it and I'm like nope
no it's not it's our house and he was
like and he just steps up into the house
and he's like are you sure I think this
is and I'm like oh my god like guide him
outside dude no no you gotta leave and I
was I was pissed because I I let him
step into the house and I was like [ __ ]
that's stupid he shouldn't have been
here cuz you're like it's so absurd that
it happens and you're totally not
prepared for it yeah yeah so you just
kind of like huh yeah and then you can
snap out of it yeah I go to and yeah
when I lived in in Boston I was home
alone cuz I was like 19 years old and
all my friends were out and I thought
that they were coming home so one prime
was in a band so I was like waiting for
their shows to be over and stuff like
that so I'm sitting in the apartment
alone and then my front door opens and
just a drunk guy not with him for a
while we trying to figure out where he
came from
but yeah they were like oh my god you
should have called the cops I was like
dunkey was fine he was like wasted and
couldn't figure out where to go
that was he kept calling me Easy Street
and he was like now I know you Easy
Street it's like do you need oh you hung
out with him well I took them out that's
what's scary
I took my - the car was like let me help
you get a cab like where did you come
from like do you have your phone like is
there someone I can call for you and he
was like wasn't giving me straight
answers so he leans over the front of a
car like this that moment like the door
opening and you're just like oh my god
someone's walking in here it's not
someone that I know you never saw a
person in it yeah because there's that
like there's no closure to this story
yeah that's part of who that was what
the intention was
in the crazy event with a crazy unlikely
event where you're actually prepared
you've a bat in your hands or whatever
right like you're just prepared to we
don't do that in Australia yeah but what
I'm saying is like you're in the state
of mind ready for something like that
which is not realistic at all but
vegging on the couch in the situation
situation where you're not vegging on
the couch and you go after him you're
like who were you know at least you see
his face or you see the guy something
but you're in no sane person is gonna go
after a guy who just broke into a your
yours like that on the front and a pump
to get it get into it you know whoever
is there whoever is there not just in
their apartment they're out doing it
yeah and so more details did you hear
footsteps okay so that was happening I
was thoroughly freetown obviously close
the door the looks on texting my brother
texting him texting him texting him no
replies he's on a date like I you know I
peeked my head out I'm like listening at
the door like against the door can't
hear anything and then after a few
minutes I'm like I wasn't gonna call the
cops I don't know why I was just freaked
out anyway I opened the door and I can't
hear anything and I look and I'm like I
kind of like take two steps into the
hallway and I look at the staircase and
it's dark it's not like you know nope oh
yeah back into the apartment
try to calm down have another beer
whatever and then I think 20 minutes
later or 10 or 20 minutes later I like
either the floor above or the floor
below or whatever I hear someone with
some form of tool I think trying to get
into an apartment so I'm like is was
this was this a burglary that was like
literally I'm gonna try and break in
here and the oh [ __ ] that's on here
close the door
my tools with it be quiet and then I
heard like I don't think yeah but I
could hear these things I'm like this
sounds like a like someone trying to
pick a lock or like
it's some sort of DN sense but in that
state of mind I was maybe like imagining
things maybe it was just someone I don't
know like whipping up a dessert and it
sounded like that but it could have been
you being paranoid it also could have
been a guy walking around the apartment
building scene trying to get into yeah
did you call the cops then no huh I
don't I'm no judgment you know I I hear
you like that Sh is terrifying it's like
Paris but also like I'm thinking but
this a nap but then I was just so
confused in it and it didn't it wasn't
your adore you adore say you were
chilling so I'm yeah I don't really know
I didn't call the cops I was just like
that so confused and like the whole
freezing thing and yeah and then Timo go
back to me like I'm on my way back I was
like okay sweet chill and so what did I
guess I was I was refusing to believe
that that was actually what was happenin
other-- question were there security
cameras in the hallways no I was like a
medium like not old old but no security
cameras and then what is your what did
your boy have to say when he got home it
got you also come on No had there been
like real audience like at that
apartment or no no we were renting it so
he was um yeah we were on the road trip
and we just had like a Airbnb there oh
that's terrifying yeah I hadn't thought
of that in a while I must have
suppressed it and you you not brought it
up is it the knock they got it out oh
yeah well that's creepy as hell I mean
that's like that's like actual real-life
creepy [ __ ] that actually happens like
people getting burglarized like [ __ ]
that we read these horror stories on
like the app of the people in our
neighborhood who have these like
break-ins and people just like going up
to the cameras and being creepy it's
like what do you mean you mean like that
happens a lot it's an app yeah that's an
app next door's ring but can I actually
because that I didn't want to tweet it I
didn't want to be insensitive oh yeah
yeah this is because you know there are
people a lot of homeless people in Los
Angeles that like I'm not trying to
judge anybody but this was actually
really funny the way they wrote it on
the app so there's a picture of a
Jacuzzi in a pool and a guy
like on someone's like property and he's
just sitting there with his hat and this
person wrote he jumped the fence and put
soap in her jacuzzi and took a bath and
still refused to leave after homeowners
videotaped him repeatedly told him to
get off our private property
he claims he co-owns our property
unbelievable the audacity he's just
sitting on the pool after he threw some
soap in it guys like come on this
poverty guy throw a chuck in soap in the
in the hot tub and he's like no it's
fine I come on this place it's mine
don't
Oh creepy Wow all right so you have some
things that you want to do mix I talk
about scary Belgian stories there are a
few things you mentioned needles hmm
there's this so literally what I did
when you're like oh do you want to be on
the podcast we don't talk about scary
stuff I was like yeah cool
scary Belgian stories is what I googled
how can I be a good guest yeah and let
me bring some value to the pin Creek
attack which is this yeah it's
apparently an 80s thing yep yes and I
think it's like a bit of you know an
urban legend that's done the rounds in
big cities but it was these stories and
they're what scare teenagers you go to
the movies and you go to check your seat
before you sit down because someone
would hide AIDS or HIV infected needles
yeah with a message on it like enjoy the
AIDS
I heard let that sit down anything what
and then you and then you know how bad
is that for here mental health when
something like that I heard I heard that
was a thing in theme parks and like yeah
like dart like at night when there would
be like scary it seemed like you know
people would go around and stab you with
so you reckon that's like Geoghan that
like happened once and then it just like
spread it's it sounds definitely way
more like an urban legend than actually
like it might have happened but if that
happened once it's too many times I know
that's just so horrifying yeah here's a
bad one I guess maybe this is just like
a bunch of urban legends I don't know
that's fine
a classic that inhaler every Belgian
hazard except for the
because I've never heard of it and I'm
glad kids get a like young kids get a
dog little doggie little puppy and the
parents leave the house and they're like
don't go outside because it's muddy and
they you know apparently for a bit to
come back and the kids played with the
dog everything you know everyone gets
wet and they're like are we gonna drive
the dog up in the microwave no that's
not a thing yeah
Oh God and also the oven the road worked
[ __ ] hell that has it's like yeah
yeah I know it's but it's a weird mix
cuz there's some of these stories that I
have heard like this one Jenna didn't
like that one the smiley face yeah I
know I'm sorry
okay what's the smile is Goga the smiley
face it's an urban legend babe it's a
European story of the so called smiley
gang or smiley face and I heard this
when I was a teenager group yeah I heard
about this I was like wait what so you'd
you know you'd get harassed by some dude
late at night you know you know a young
woman and he'd be like you can you can
choose like we either you know two
horrible things to you or you can smile
forever and always said I come in a
small River and then they would cut like
you're you you open and when the Joker
bit yeah it's something like that and
they would put like some I think it was
like some form is-8 or like like lemon
juice said that the scars would like be
[ __ ] and yeah this is [ __ ] yeah I
know right these are anyways these are
like you know pretty bad herbal engines
here's another one which isn't as bad
this is more like the supernatural yeah
yeah it's forests I got it here another
tampon yeah alright I'm ready for a
forest story four stories not gonna be
better baby this is a spooky spot in
Belgium
hello and it's a forest near Brussels
where I went to school called the de OG
en I don't know how you say it in
English do good do good or something
like that something like that and
there's this fog there and it's about
the fog and people have described this
fog being white grey orange green the
organ in Dutch is the organ which is the
eyes and all these tails are different
but what they
all described what every time it comes
back in these stories about this weird
fog in this one specific tourist is that
they would hear kids laughing and they
would see like mini like little figures
through the fog [ __ ] yeah and then the
fog you like be at your car and then
they would see like handprints bloody
handprints on your car yeah so that like
the I'm like oh you know maybe the you
know atmospheric whatever is there's fog
there but the so many different stories
coming back about these little figures
that you know thank you
want to go to this forest nope
absolutely not
yeah that's horrifying Thanks hearing
kids laughing in any setting with other
than when there are actually kids
laughing is scary it's not right
yeah shouldn't happen to so I found
something I was scrolling through okay
so I was like lucky I was literally
looking for like a scary [ __ ]
right I was trying to find like it was
like Julian what scares you and I
couldn't really think of you know but I
found this thing where this woman I'm
gonna try to find that I or whatever
yeah
this woman Oh God okay oh and blue I saw
a glimpse of it hold on I know we're
gonna put it on screen so you're gonna
see it oh yeah yeah so I'm just trying
to find here it is I'm sick so it's
basically this woman who made these
dolls I'm gonna pass on this one
okay it's called it's called reborn baby
calm not a sponsor of the podcast it's a
website of an artist who displays and
sells her handcrafted baby dolls called
reborn babies okay and it's the last
three yeah just look to the last three
the eyes the [ __ ] eyes it's too real
I don't like it because it's it's what's
that thing we're the tough robots are
like close to human but you can send
something's off yeah this looks very
real but something's often you know that
something Jenna don't say that's not
scary because that thing's gonna be
there it's scary but like um I think
that audio of someone being possessed by
a demon
okay are we having a contest here we
know I'm gonna say like I think that
that this being scary is subjective
because I'm not super scared by that was
it yeah but it's an adult super scary
dolls are a little creepy this general
for some reason it's like this skin tone
it's the eyes like look at the skin tone
you don't mean like they replicated yeah
really yeah it's translation it reminds
me of that episode of black mirror when
yeah she gets a boyfriend but no no she
no it's like her boyfriend who dies and
gets remade version of boyfriend yes yes
this is the name of the website baby
baby babies yeah can you put your baby
reborn into a baby
you like my thing my thing isn't so much
as like looking at a picture of this is
like yeah sure it's scary but like this
is a real person who makes these real
creepy ass [ __ ] dolls that look
exactly like babies what the [ __ ] does
this person do on their free time
besides make babies your art is probably
a mother she probably loves her babies
why are you so are you so confident in
trusting of this person who makes fake
babies she made a beautiful artistic
doll I'm not scared by it I think she
was probably a lovely lady hmm
Wow I'm not scared okay I don't want one
no I'm getting you a baby all right now
the biggest one it's not scary
a giant lifelike baby is scary that's
scary I'm another one I found was so
it's kind of like one of those things
that you have to experience in the right
order to understand why it's creepy but
basically it's called EDM dark side of
YouTube and basically it's this guy who
he
this older dude right and he checks all
the boxes of like an old guy on YouTube
it's like kind of being funny and it's
like stupid and out of touch but it's
like trying to you know like an old
person making videos like trying to be
relatable but it's like an old person
making videos and so it's charming
in that sense don't say me yep it's
charming in that sense right but then
basically like his background you look
him up and he's got this horrible
registered sexual sex offender that's
terrible background and so then all of
his videos like take on a whole
different meaning
oh no yeah it's pretty [ __ ] imagine
being like a fan
yeah like exactly Oh mate before me fear
is so good love you stuff yeah and then
you you found out that you've been but
that that was literally the experience
of some people they were like oh this
guy made a reaction video a lip sync and
then you look back and you're like oh
god and he liked that songs he chose
like yeah but he's on tilt oh yeah well
he he I think at one point he was he was
convicted yeah so he was convicted in
1987 and God he's got it's creepy
it's creepy speaking of people but it's
it's creepy what you mentioned that talk
oh you saw oh yeah that don't seriously
cuz I know you guys are in a triangle
look it up don't watch it it was so
disturbed going to its I forget his name
but he's a cannibal and he's Chinese I
want to say but I'll I'll look it up but
it's on [ __ ] YouTube he's he's free
and it's like a documentary about him
talking about killing and cutting up and
eating women and like how he felt and
what he thinks about it's so deeply
disturbing yeah why I don't know I don't
when when a long time ago but he's he's
not yeah everything about it's just
wrong the fact that someone did that and
is now not in jail is they said ah was
that his name I don't know
named [ __ ] house
sorry yeah it's terrible to say Segawa
is his name
sorry he's Japanese yeah like the serial
killer thing the people who like the
cannibalistic serial killers the people
who don't literally you're not capable
of feeling remorse disturbing
it's disturbing because it's like a
different species it's not a human right
it's like the things that they're doing
and they're capable of and they're proud
of and they this guy's [ __ ] free in
the world talking about that's scary
because it's like it's you're no longer
up against another person right like
that's a different thing that's a thing
so that's pretty [ __ ] up hmm really
[ __ ] do you have any like ghost
stories ever had any like interactions
aside from a door opening that you can't
explain that door opening was a person
it's scary though maybe not that's true
like it's not really that scary but it
stands out because I was young and when
you're young whatever happens it's the
first time that it happens so it's got
like more weight to it I was biking as
on my bike my bicycle on the way to
school and oh there's another one I just
remembered another one um looking to my
right I grew up in a really for like a
forest pretty much like yeah huge trees
Irvine Sweden I'm looking in okay and I
see this vision of a guy walking with
the dog but it looked a bit off and I
was like like it's a you shouldn't be
there there's no walkways there's no
pass or tree yeah I just by myself and
then Luke and how does that go out
that's strange for like probably a
fracked like a flash like a fraction of
a second and I come to a tea you know
you know team that the street ends and I
can go left to right and usually I go
right or left
it's like there was always a dispute
between friends which way was fastest to
go to school cuz it's like the next
block was where the school was
and I went left where usually I go right
I don't know why I said go left I look
right and there's a guy walking his dog
it like exactly like this weight like it
like a repeated vision of it like you
said yeah but I remember saying he
passed him no no no so he was in
right on the right path like he went
when he left house like that something
just felt weird about it
so something about weird the first time
you saw well I saw I didn't see him
because there was no one in the forest
but I thought I saw a man with a dog
walking in the forest to my ride
and then like 30 meters later there's
that crossing where I chose to go left
instead of right and there was that one
right actually a dude with a dog it was
a glitch in the tribulation yeah exactly
it could have been nothing could have
been to me at the time it was so strange
yeah and I was like thinking about it
all day long well what was that what it
what happened like why is it literally
just like I was thinking and like
imagining someone and then it's like a
numbers game like every now and then
something happens that's just weird but
it's just a coincidence and then another
moment that stuck with me forever was I
was at my grandparents or on holiday in
Austin karakia which is near dunkirk ok
where the film was and the war and I
experienced a lapse in time that's weird
for a gap a gap in time because I was
sitting on the couch and I stand up and
I blink and I'm in the other corner of
the room I was really young like I got
years old you blink and you're no longer
standing where you like in hindsight
probably stood up too fast it's been
kind of like brain like freaking out
whatever but at the time I was like what
just happened see you were freaked out
when it happened yeah yeah and it was
again because I was so you know as a
child you're so impressionable and
everything that happens this is new and
I've never had that happened before I
was like 4 years and even now think in
fact it was like whoa what was that was
that I think maybe you're looking back
and trying to explain it but you
teleported these are both things that
can like relate to like a you know like
the jumping time lines you know what I
mean time being like yeah that's the
thing that I thought of like always this
like a crossover like yeah you could be
alternate that's I'm saying like both
unrelated
TimeWalker basically well you're in the
right profession cuz you maybe for what
do I warp time that's my job how crazy
that is crazy
Oh from all the time that you've worked
on your camera you have to deal with it
in your real life you you get get like
paid back at that time but it like comes
in chunks that's a cool that's a story
right there that's a screen gonna start
running it's true that's right a dude
all right well we got to go write a
script so see ya later know do you
thanks for coming on the podcast thanks
for talking about such a fun time for
those who I encourage everybody to just
give him a like and check out his stuff
it's really really impressive if you
like time-lapses he is one of my biggest
inspirations when it comes to time
lapsing and getting the film together
again this week I know I told you
off-camera like it's been a huge fire
lit
relive my ass and I'm like very excited
thanks so again so yeah well link his
stuff below check him out he's Matt Jo's
on all this all the things but thanks
for being on the podcast yeah so much
yeah we captured you from Australia and
you made it on the podcast we'll be back
next week with another podcast probably
with one less person we'll see and it
will be scary we promise that the last
episode you know will also be scary but
you guys have a wonderful and spooky
week we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]